يعني استانفت القوات الاوكرانيه قصفه
لمدينه
بمجموعات من صواريخ مختلفه صواريخ جراد
تشيكيه الصنع وفامبير بولنديه الصنع كما
ان صواريخ هايمرز خلال اليومين الماضيين
استهدفت مناطق عديده في قلب مدينه خلف
القصف عشره قتله واعداد من الاصابات بعد
هدوء عم المدينه لمده اسبوعين تقريبا هذا
القصف تزامن مع تصريحات الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين بان اهميه ابعاد القوات
الاوكرانيه عن مناطق المدنيين في دانيتك
وان مهمه جيش الروسي هي وقف اطلاق النار
في دمباس بالفعل هناك يعني معارك ضاريه ما
زال القصم متبادل نسمع الاصوات اطلاق
النار من هنا من دانيسك وكذلك سقوط
القذائف في مناطق مختلفه اهمها المناطق
الغربيه الماليه الغربيه من المدينه
بالفعل هناك معارك ضاريه في محاور مختلفه
اذا سمح لنا الوقت احمدنا نتحدث عن باخمت
وهو المحور الاهم كما اسلفت فان قوات تعلن
بعد سيطرتها على مناطق او المباني
الاداريه في قلب المدينه تعلن تقدمها الى
مناطقك الحديديه وانها تخوض معارك شرسه
كما ان معارك ضاريه ايضا تدور في المحور
الشمالي في بلده
اريخكا ايضا الاله العسكريه الروسيه تعمل
من الناحيه الشرقيه والناحيه الجنوبيه كما
ان المقاتلات هناك في باخمت في هذين
المحورين الشرقي والجنوبي تقصف باستمرار
قواعد تمركز القوات الاوكرانيه داخل
المدينه في عمق المدينه ما زالت الامدادات
تصل للقوات الاوكرانيه عن طريق شاسوفار
مدينه شاسوفيار في المنطقه الغربيه نعم
حيث عجزت قوات فاجنر عن اقتحام بلده
بقدونسكا التي تمكنها من اكمال الطوق من
الناحيه الغربيه كما ان المنطقه الشرقيه
ما زالت تتقدم فيها القوات الروسيه وتسيطر
على مناطق عديده اهمها المصانع
والمعامل التي معامل اللحوم عموما الانباء
الورد ايضا من ومارينكا ايضا تشير الى
معارك عنيفه ووضع متوتر جدا في هذا التين
منطقتين ما الذي يمكن ان تخبرنا به ايضا
عن ذلك لدينا ربما اقل من دقيقتين راي
تفضل
نعم احمد
المدينتان المتاخمتان لقلب العاصمه قلب
المقاطعه وهي العاصمه تتقدم القوات
الروسيه محاوله اقتحام مدينه
لكنها لم تستطع اقتحامها حتى الان الفرقه
الخامسه عشر هي التي تقوم بالمهام
العسكريه حول مدينه ابديفكا هناك استخدام
لاسلحه متطوره في هذا المحور هناك مقاومه
عنيفه من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه كما ان
مدينه مارينكا تقدم فيها الجيش الروسي
وسيطر على ثلثي المدينه وما زالت القوات
الاوكرانيه تسيطر على الثلث الاخير دون اي
تقدم في المرحله الاخيره لكن المعارك
مستمره ويوميا هناك محاولات اقتحام من
الجانب الروسي
يعني لم لم لم تفلح حتى الان هذه
المحاولات
رامز
وتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات